apparently there's a lot of bear grylls
fans out there you've asked me to watch
the scenes comment on their medical
accuracy and safety
i'm about to do that let's get started
but first a huge thank you to thrive
market for sponsoring this video
you'll need water but if there isn't any
you can drink
your own pee no bear come on
psa do not drink your own pee if you
drink
what your body excreted especially if
you're already borderline dehydrated
you're going to be getting rid of all
the stuff that you don't need and then
taking it back in i know we sometimes
say you're in a sterile it's not
there's bacteria then you're going to be
drinking it now you're giving yourself
diarrhea potentially another
fever-causing illness which is going to
dehydrate you further and there's other
uses for your pee
put it on your clothes and put it on
your skin so that when it evaporates it
cools you down
might not smell great but you'll survive
come on bear and if i just peed on the
ground
that's all those fluids wasted they're
not wasted because fluid management
within your body
is not just fluids it's fluids plus
minus electrolytes and what your body
does in urine is it gets rid
of those electrolytes that it doesn't
need and it keeps a very careful balance
when you
drink your urine you're essentially
throwing that off
further and further each time so like no
do not drink urine i'm gonna eat some
thrive seaweed
while he drinks that urine also salty
much tastier no not my favorite
no that's not the gatorade flavor you go
for
urine is actually 95 water and it's
sterile when fresh
it's not because it has to go through
your pee hole which sometimes has
bacteria in it and drink it sooner
rather than later as it's a breeding
ground for bacteria how does bear grylls
say
that his urine is sterile meaning it has
no bacteria and then say it's a breeding
ground for bacteria where's the bacteria
come from
one thing you can do if you're stuck out
here with no water source at all is not
to drink your own urine
it's actually drink the fluid from a
fresh elephant down
oh my god does he just try and find
liquid
anywhere he can pretty disgusting yeah
it could save your life
it's that all of this is so
temporary it's incredible there is so
much bacteria in that
water that we will give you diarrhea
thereby dehydrate you this makes
no sense wow i'll tell you what these
these are the biggest grubs i've ever
seen look
and this is just the sort of place that
they like they feed off all this
rotting soft interior of the palm tree
just think about that
do you want to eat a bug that was just
eating the rotten
interior of a palm tree and actually the
locals eat a lot of these they're like a
delicacy
they're full of good protein when he
says good protein
does he mean it it'll be worth every one
of its 140 calories
cook it my guy holy smoke
that is gosh
horrible yeah do you know what they can
keep their delicacies
like i've seen people eat insects and
crickets and stuff before and they do
have protein
but like the cooking part is just
mandatory
is that what i'm looking for is
the stomach how does he know
the anatomy of animals there's three
parts so it can separate
the liquids from the solids wow and the
bit i want
is called the rumen i see the fascia
there
this room and water is just like a
reservoir
oh my god i can't imagine that that
is safe to drink and a nomad
told me once how his uncle
in the 1950s was lost in a sandstorm out
here
and he actually ended up killing his
camel
to get at the rumen
and all this fluid inside and that
actually saved his life
as an evidence-based physician i don't
like hearing anecdotes like that that
some guy
one time 200 years ago saved his life by
killing his camel that like proves
nothing to me that
story could have been made up it could
have been embellished it doesn't mean
that everyone should be killing camels
and drinking their room in water i don't
know it just it sounds so extreme
and look inside you can see everything
that's been eating
which is what that's just grass sort of
partially digested
and the fluid in this again is no
he's gonna drink the gastric juices of a
camel
no come on oh
my god bear grylls the type of guy
five million years ago to see a cow
utter and just see fluid and just start
sucking on
it back to bear grylls in just a second
but first let me tell you about thrive
market
watching bear grylls eat stuff in the
wild really makes me grateful for their
online marketplace where you can save
money and get amazing products my
patients always worry about how to eat
healthy or
get responsible products but keep it
somewhat reasonable too expensive i get
it the beauty of thrive market is that
you have thousands of products with
guaranteed savings
home beauty even pet products for bear
and the simple part about it is when
you're browsing the website you can
organize it based on the diet
or values that are important to you
paleo vegan keto whatever you want
it's all there all orders are delivered
with carbon neutral shipping
and their warehouses are zero waste the
cool part is you can choose whichever
membership fits your lifestyle best
one month 12 month for me the 12 month
package at five bucks a month is really
the most reasonable choice and that's
the one i recommend to my friends and
family now you can even sign up for an
auto ship and get an additional five to
ten percent off
and never run out of your favorite
products sign up right now and you're
gonna get 25
off your first order and a free gift all
you have to do is visit the link down
below thrive market dot com
slash dr mike remember dr mike is
spelled out and don't worry about
getting the full year because it's 30
days risk-free let's get back to bear
grylls
you can eat these things straight out of
the river like that
oh my god why does he it's like he does
it on purpose
just what my body needs to keep moving
i'm going to take
full advantage of this feast it's kind
of weird to me that as a survival
specialist
he makes no use of fire here fire was
invented for a reason to cook things
to prevent infections because one of the
leading killers
before fire before the use of cooking
our food storing our food correctly was
diarrhea it would dehydrate you
electrolyte imbalance your heart would
stop acute kidney failure
i've noticed a lot of bees in the area
so i'm heading through the scrub
to get to the hive and find some honey
you know i'm a honey fan
like i love honey honey works as good or
better than over-the-counter cough
suppressants in the pediatric population
oh that looks fresh fresh honeycomb
leaving my forehead exposed was a real
oversight if you
get a really bad sting and you happen to
be an individual who is severely
allergic to a beast thing
you go into anaphylactic shock where
your throat closes up your blood
pressure drops that could be lethal
very very quickly that's why if you know
you have an allergy you should have an
epipen like that on hand at all times
not necessarily an epipen any kind of
epinephrine auto injector oh he's
swelling
it's made all of you know this part of
me swell up
allergic reaction that's serious edema
right there fatal
i'm worried about anaphylactic shock the
first signs are swelling around the eyes
followed by difficulty breathing and
loss of consciousness
these type of large reactions are really
treated with supportive care if it's not
true anaphylactic
shock you want to think cold compresses
steroids in serious cases and really
just making sure that the patient's
airway is not compromised their blood
pressure remains stable
once that's okay that usually does pass
in a few days but
swelling on its own if it's not over the
airway is not intrinsically dangerous
i'm on a raft in the pacific ocean i've
collected some fresh water
but it's full of bird droppings and it's
rancid drink this
and you'd probably vomit and risk worse
than dehydration
but there is a way of using it to gain
life-giving fluids
but only as a last resort i don't even
know what he's about to do but the fact
that it has bird droppings
makes me think that there's so much e
coli in it that if it makes any contact
with the inside of your body whether
it's through a cut or you drinking it
you're just gonna get a massive
infection and a massive infection when
you're stranded and you're surviving
is like the worst case scenario i'm
gonna give myself
an enema oh oh my god
he doesn't try and survive he's got to
think what is the most
ridiculous extreme thing i can do in
order to make this show
could you absorb fluids from your rectum
yes
there are small blood vessels there we
do give suppositories there so there are
absorptive
qualities there oh my god i can't even
think about this there's also a lot of
bacteria that lives in your rectum
including e coli which doesn't enter
your bloodstream
so it could be an okay place to have
some bacteria there's just
so much that could go wrong i think it's
like a 50 50 shot will you survive or
will you kill yourself further
no that's that's that's placenta
oh my god somebody had a baby is that
shack what's rare though is find it so
fresh
that for me is good news is it good news
it looks actually like dinner shaq don't
do it buddy i've seen you three-peat i
mean this is a
this is a first for me to eat placenta
yeah it should be a last
like there are some cultures that do
this because the placenta is like it has
the nutrients and it does the oxygen
distribution for the baby through the
umbilical cord and there's some cultures
that think about doing this but like the
cdc has put out a specific warning like
do not do this
if you get a groupie strep infection in
your placenta and then you eat it and
then you pass it to your baby to like
breast milk that's deadly that's lethal
to a newborn
i give him props i wouldn't do it
shaq is my man it's traditional for
berber men
to eat goat's testicles they're thought
to enhance fertility
and it's certainly going to be a test to
my manhood look i'm respectful of all
cultures
the line i draw is medical
misinformation if you're gonna tell me
eating a goat's nut
is gonna help you get fertile i'm not
gonna buy it i need evidence-based
medicine for that
why raw just put it over a flame well
that's definitely a first for me
see he's throwing up because there's
bacteria and it's gross and what this
stuff is is like
sunblock oh wow and the coral itself we
use this at low tide
where it's exposed to the sun it will
secrete this as a way of protecting
itself
just amazing wow scientists actually
reckon this stuff
is like as good as factor 50. wow and
spf 50 is pretty great protection i mean
like i always say get the highest spf
possible
even though like once you get above 50
not much is changing but that's
only if you're following the exact
guidelines and i don't know about this
whole mushroom thing
like just get the one from the store if
it's got tentacles like that
those are stingers but so you can't eat
it jelly for scary like the body of it
right boil it up i mean it's a bit like
tastes a bit like gelatin
it's pure protein i don't know what the
deal is with eating jellyfish
i missed that day in residency and in
medical school folks today we're
learning about eating jellyfish it's
like peanut butter and jelly but with
fish but those are the those
it got you know yeah pepper so he got
stung by a jelly oh and he put in his
mouth
movies before where if somebody gets
stung by a jellyfish you have to pee on
them the whole thing with peeing on a
jellyfish thing really comes from
preventing like the discharge of more
toxin and creating more inflammation the
general consensus has been to use
seawater
and not to use fresh water especially
because it can cause more of that toxin
to be released
if you just relax then i'll relax now
i've got stage fright i can't relax
to pee on demand when somebody's in pain
is very difficult
peeing is actually a complex neurologic
process it's
very easy to throw that off if for
example you've had a stroke
if you had an injury to that area it's
very easy to uh
develop urinary incontinence or urinary
retention and sometimes the treatment
for that is actually like biofeedback
and understanding
how to control different muscles in the
area i've been in water
this cold before oh he's going swimming
in cold water playing horrible
yeah it's horrible just getting
undressed chilly
okay well i'm hooked up to this
transmitter as well and that's just
showing my heart rate
but also my breathing rate generally
what happens is when you hit
really cold temperatures like that or go
underwater a lot of times you'll have
this like diving reflex
where your body will automatically send
you into a bradycardic rhythm where the
electrical activity of your heart
actually slows down to allow you to
survive
longer underwater we actually used to
use this type of treatment for
supraventricular tachycardia where we
actually got patients to perform this
diving reflex vagal maneuver and it
would reset their heart rhythm
slow it down obviously needs to be very
carefully monitored and now with the new
medications we have on board we
generally don't have to do this
[Music]
oh i'm cold for him i'm cold for him
watch as my heart rate drops from 160
beats per minute
to 55. yep diving mammalian dive reflex
it gives you vital extra seconds to make
it to the surface
you did it see it worked the survival
mechanism kicked in we actually also use
hypothermia
treatment in patients who are undergoing
prolonged cardiac arrest
where we realize that if we put them
through a hypothermia protocol very
controlled we actually
decrease the oxygen demand on the body
on certain organs
therefore we give them a little bit
longer survival time
bear grylls certainly does a lot of cool
stuff on the ground but i just flew an
f-16
in the sky here's what happens to your
body when you're flying in an f-16 and
experiencing a lot of g's
click here to check that out and again
huge thank you to thrive market for
sponsoring this video
click down below to get 25 off your
first order and a free gift
as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]
you